[Musique]
quand on m'a contacté pour participer à
félix marseille on m'a demandé de
raconter mon histoire et on m'a expliqué
que le thème de l'année s'étaient défiés
l'impossible ça collait parfaitement
défier l'impossible vous y croyez vous
et on m'a dit que tout ça devait tenir
dans dix-huit minutes 18 minutes c'est
le temps que j'ai aujourd'hui devant
vous pas une de plus mais dix-huit
minutes
c'est aussi le temps qu'il a fallu pour
que mon univers s'écroule et qu'on me
prive d'une partie de mon innocence
on dit souvent qu'impossible n'est pas
français
aujourd'hui j'en suis certaine pour vous
parler un petit peu de moi je suis né à
marseille et j'ai grandi entre traite et
aix en provence
mira des villes mais rat des champs avec
un héritage plutôt campagnard du côté de
mon papa et des habitudes plus citadine
du côté de maman bref un vrai petit mix
une jeune fille tout ce qu'il ya de plus
banal tout ce qu'il ya de plus normal si
tant est qu'on puisse définir vraiment
ce qu'est la normalité mais vous voyez
tout me réussissait
c'est incroyable j'étais la première de
ma classe championne régionale de danse
championne de france d'équitation
j'avais le petit copain dans toutes les
filles rêvent et la vie de top pour une
adolescente vous trouvez pas que tout me
réussit ce changement mais je ne me
rendais pas quant à ce moment-là de la
chance que j'avais est en fait à bien y
réfléchir
tout me réussissait peut-être un peu
trop
c'était louche fallait bien que quelque
chose se passe pour me ramener les pieds
sur terre
sans mauvais jeu de mots 30 juillet 2002
16 heures un soleil de plomb
mon copain et moi on décide de prendre
un scooter pour se rendre chez une amie
à est centre ville c'est moi qui conduis
un rond point je tourne à droite une
grande avenue est là un chauffard qui
nous dépasse qui nous fait une queue de
poisson
mon copain est éjecté il s'en tirera
mieux que moi moi je suis placardées
dans la barrière centrale là tout
s'effondre
le casque l'équipement rien a suffi je
ne sens plus mes jambes je ne peux plus
bouger
je vois tout le monde qui s'agite autour
de moi je comprends alors que c'est
grave je n'entends plus rien si le
crissement des pneus de la voiture qui
est en train de prendre la fuite
et mon coeur qui bat si fort dans ma
poitrine que j'ai l'impression qu'il va
exploser
mais je suis bien vous savez le corps
humain est bien fait dans ces cas là je
n'avais mal nulle part mais j'avais
sommeil j'ai commencé à m'endormir
alors on sait dans ces situations qu'il
faut résister s'accrocher lutte et
j'étais épuisée et là je sentais que je
partais tout à coup deux grands yeux
bleus mais d'un bleu immense en était
presque douloureux qui me supplient de
rester là c'est le moment où je me
demande si je suis pas passé déjà de
l'autre côté du tunnel quand même hein
en fait c'était les yeux bleus du
pompier qui allait me sauver la vie ce
pompier qui avait terminé son service et
qui est passé quand même qui a pris
quelques minutes de sa vie pour essayer
de sauver la mienne sans lui je ne
serais pas là je me suis quand même dit
ma pauvre fille qui est en train de
mourir et en même temps tu mates le beau
gosse au dessus de toi ça fait pas très
sérieux parce que vous en pensez mais
n'empêche que ses yeux c'est ce qui m'a
permis de tenir et ses yeux c'est la
dernière chose que j'ai vue avant de
m'endormir pour un très long moment
les semaines passent et je me réveille
environ trois semaines plus tard en
réanimation mais j'ai pas la notion du
temps qui est passé pour moi l'accident
c'était hier hélas bilan dramatique
bassin tout fracturé les deux fémur
cassé artère fémorale sectionnée jambe
droite amputée
waouh on sait même pas si je vais
pouvoir remarcher
mais qu'est ce que je vais devenir
j'étais une danseuse hier une danseuse
sur un pied c'est quoi un flamant rose
je suis plus rien et les garçons
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont penser les garçons
les petits copains s'en va les amis
enfin que je pensais être des amis s'en
vont également même temps à 17 ans c'est
pas drôle de venir voir un copain en
réanimation je vous la corde mais bon ça
inquiète quand même parce qu'on se dit
si des gens qui étaient censés nous
apprécier pour autre chose pour que
notre que notre enveloppe physique ils
partent mais qui voudra bien de moi qui
s'approchera de moi alors on vous
explique qu'il va falloir réussir à
réintégrer un nouveau schéma corporel
jusqu'à mes 17 ans j'ai vécu avec deux
pieds il va falloir que je reprogramme
mon cerveau pour lui dire et au
maintenant il y en a plus qu'un ok allez
lui dire ça votre cerveau quand toutes
les nuits ce pied que vous n'avez plus
vous démange terriblement et qui a rien
à gratter rien ça s'appelle le membre
fantôme
c'est terrible on vous dit aussi qu'il
va falloir réussir à se réapproprier son
corps un corps qu'on ne reconnaît pas
mais à l'hôpital c'est pas simple parce
qu'on a aucune intimité pour vous
expliquer un petit peu pendant plusieurs
mois je n'ai pas eu le droit de poser un
pied en dehors du lit ni même de
m'asseoir vous imaginez dans quel état
de dépendance totale j'étais pour les
actes les plus élémentaires
je vous passe les détails de la vie
quotidienne le matin je me rappelle
encore je priais pour que ça soit une
infirmière et si possible d'un certain
âge images maternelle rassurantes je
pense qu'ils ouvrent la porte de la
chambre pour me dire c'est pour la
toilette mais c'était pas toujours le
cas
et un jour la porte s'ouvre et là
bonjour mademoiselle c pour la toilette
un grand brun ténébreux comme on les
aime
et puis là à non non non non je crois
que ça va pas être possible de faire la
grève de la toilette pour au moins une
semaine là
et bien non on peut pas faire la grève
de la toilette c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche
imaginez que ce gène la veille parce que
pour moi c'était la veille quand j'avais
encore mais de gens j'aurais pu le
rencontrer en soirée dansante il
m'aurait peut-être abordé en aurait
discuté et là je suis sur un lit doit
m'aider à faire ma toilette
imaginez un petit peu votre dignité y'a
plus rien mais ce qui m'intrigue c'est
pourquoi ces moments simples on les
apprécie qu'une fois qu'on les a perdus
quand même étrange les mois passent je
fais ma rééducation
je me bats pour remarcher et ça
fonctionne et je sors de ce centre de
rééducation et là tout customiser des
plaques en faire partout façon iron man
coke aux dernières nouvelles il paraît
qu'il est mort donc on va peut-être
évité la référence n'empêche que je sors
avec mon fauteuil roulant mes béquilles
et ma prothèse zelaya un choix qui
s'impose à moi soit je décide que ce
tube en faire ça va être un tremplin
vers une nouvelle vie pleine de
surprises soit il sera un fardeau que je
vais traîner toute ma vie perso le choix
a été vite fait mais quand même
tout devient un défi quand on est
handicapé
et quand on sort du centre de
rééducation que j'avais envie d'aller
faire du shopping ça m'avait manqué
forcément mais en fauteuil bah c'est
compliqué même si on va vers du mieux
tout n'est pas encore assez accessible
mais ça avant j'y pensais pas parce
qu'il y avait moi puis avait les
handicapés il y avait eu il y avait moi
le handicap ça n'arrive qu'aux autres
ça c'est ce que je pensais avant mais du
jour vous passez une journée assis dans
un fauteuil roulant
vous comprenez si vous remarquez qu'il
ne sera plus jamais possible de vous
garer sur une place handicapée si vous
n'y avez pas droit en disant j'en ai que
pour deux minutes
parce que la personne handicapée qui
arrive à ce moment là qui n'a pas de
place assez large pour pouvoir ouvrir sa
portière prendre son fauteuil le
descendre balle rentre chez elle elle a
terminé sa journée mais ça moi à
l'époque
ça me passer au dessus je me rendais pas
compte
deuxième chose en sortant du centre de
rééducation qui maintiennent qui
m'intriguait c'est le regard des gens
savaient ce regard qui vous rappellent
en permanence que vous avez un problème
c'est quelque chose de différent chez
vous alors vous savez ce qu'ils vous
infantiliser qui vous parle comme un
gosse de 5 ans allez comprendre
mais vous avez su aussi ça c'est le top
du top qui vous parlent fort ça va
mademoiselle aujourd'hui oui ça va je
suis amputé mais je suis pas devenu ce
pour autant
allez comprendre c'est un peu étrange de
francs cézanne et se passe seize
opérations quand même 16 allers retours
entre l'hôpital la maison la maison
l'hôpital si bien que je suis incapable
de vous dire aujourd'hui si j'ai passé
plus de temps à l'hôpital où la maison
et lors de mes différents séjours à
l'hôpital
ouais j'aime bien dire séjour parce que
je me sens je pars en vacances
lors de mes différents séjours à
l'hôpital
je rencontre souvent des personnes qui
se retrouvent en situation de handicap
et qui pensent que parce qu'elles ont
perdu un bout elles sont foutues et à
l'époque du haut de mes 17 ans je me
sentais mais tellement impuissante
je savais pas quoi faire pour les aider
j'avais pas les moyens et je me
culpabiliser presque d'avoir moi la
chance d'avoir cette rage de vaincre que
n'avait pas forcément
et 2017 je me dis je dois faire quelque
chose je décide de créer l'association
handi dream andy dream comme son nom
l'indiqué aller au bout de ses rêves
malgré son handicap mais je préfère
désormais dire graff au handicap
notre objectif aller dans les centres
voir ces personnes et leur donner de
l'énergie parce que pas tout le monde a
la chance d'être entouré et quand vous
vous retrouvez en situation de handicap
déjà vous reconnaissez plus votre corps
mais si en plus de ça l'entourage s'en
va c'est tout votre univers qui
s'effondre moi j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
la famille s'est pas toujours le cas
2019 je décide de réaliser mon rêve je
vous disais que j'étais cavaliere alors
c'est parti pour un tour de france à
cheval mais je n'oublie pas pour autant
toutes ces personnes dans les centres de
rééducation et je décide d'aller leur
dire que quel que soit le moyen
le principal c'est d'aller au bout de
ses rêves mars 2019 nous voilà partis
mon papa 70 ans
toujours partant pour l'aventuré nos
deux chevaux et mon chien spy assistant
que vous voyez là pour une aventure d'un
cinq mois de périple 3600 km à cheval on
allait rencontrer des personnes
extraordinaires les lundis on passe dans
les centres de rééducation et là quand
on arrive on se retrouve confronté dès
fois à des patients qui vous disent jeu
sert plus à rien je suis handicapé ma
femme est partie j'ai perdu mon travail
à quoi bon on me dit de me battre mais
pourquoi pourquoi
et là on a très peu de temps pour les
convaincre que même avec un petit bout
en moins la vie elle mérite d'être vécue
et les animaux se positionne comme
d'excellents médiateur il se passe des
choses magiques
il crée le lien et quand moi je met pied
à terre
je suis déjà dans l'intimité du patient
la relation est déjà créée il ya pas
besoin de forcer le patient se confie et
je peux alors rapidement le conseiller
on parle d'appareillage on parle de
reprise du sport de conduite du véhicule
du regard des gens de la place des
aidants on parle des relations
tim toutes ces questions qui nous trotte
dans la tête quand on est hospitalisé et
auxquels ne peuvent pas toujours
répondre les blouses blanches ça c'était
les lundis les mardis on passe dans les
écoles parce que je parlais tout à
l'heure de faire changer ce regard sur
le handicap ce regard qui est perturbant
quand on sort du centre de rééducation
et que tout le monde bloque sur cette
différence
si on veut faire évoluer les conceptions
il faut s'adresser aux enfants les
enfants c'est l'avenir
et banaliser cette différence donc on
leur expliquait que le principal même si
on est tous différents
c'est de vivre tous ensemble et ce sont
nos différences qui font nos forces ce
qu'on a essayé aussi c'est de
déconstruire leurs idées tout reçu tout
fait du handicap car ils me regardent
comme ça ils me l'ont dit clairement en
figures et puis sans filtre c'est ça qui
est bien qu'ils pensent que je suis
foutu je ne peux pas conduire
je n'aurais jamais mari quelle idée je
n'aurais surtout pas d'enfant et puis en
plus je dois voir aucun rêve donc on
essaye de lever les tabous et de
répondre à leurs questions parfois les
plus insolites
il y en a qui m'ont demandé si en
parlant avec moi ils risquaient pas
d'attraper la maladie de la jambe coupée
je vous rassure c'est pas contagieux on
a deux qui m'ont demandé si mes enfants
risqué de naître avec une jambe en moins
j'espère pas mais le plus mignon c'est
un petit garçon qui m'a demandé si ma
jambe à les repousser
je lui dis ben non mon bonhomme elle
repoussera pas une fois que j'ai coupé c
coupé m'a dit oui mais c'est pas juste
madame j'ai dit pourquoi c'est pas juste
parce que la queue du lézard elle
repousse alors pourquoi pas ta jambe
c'était juste adorable et pour organiser
toute cette aventure on a rencontré des
difficultés
et puis c'est la vie avec le handicap au
quotidien je peux pas vous dire que tout
est simple c'est un leurre ce n'est pas
simple mais c'est possible avec des
adaptations et avec la volonté
par exemple pour faire différentes
activités j'ai besoin de différentes
prothèse une seule prothèse ne peut pas
tout faire donc là vous avez prothèses
de bain prothèses de cheval blonde mais
il n'existait pas de pied prothétique
d'équitation on aurait pu s'en tenir là
et l'irb en battant puis on laisse
tomber banon mon papa à partir d'une
truelle
vous aurez compris qu'il était maçon a
décidé de me créer un pied donc j'ai du
rebond et à cheval
je suis super bien comme avant
l'accident
on a amené cette cruelle chez les
prothésistes et on est en train de faire
un prototype que j'ai testé pendant le
tour de france au top
une deuxième difficulté ses ouvriers
vous avez remarqué je suis pas bien
grande
mon cheval l'huile un peu trop à mon
goût et par rapport à mes difficultés de
dos de hanche et ben on lui a appris à
se baisser pour m'aider il se baisse et
je peux monter dessus
je suis complètement autonome pas s'il y
en a qui ont déjà été en fauteuil
roulant mais quand vous partez faire vos
courses et que vous êtes en fauteuil
roulant si vous faites avancer le
fauteuil depuis prêt à porter les sacs
cabas
alors vous avez la technique sac à dos
ou prendre dans un bras mais si vous
tenez dans un bras bas vous tournez en
rond dont vous n'allez pas bien loin non
plus hein du coup on s'est dit on va
apprendre à part mon assistant a poussé
le fauteuil roulant alors ce pas il
ramasse aussi tout ce que je fais tomber
sur le sol parce que c'est compliqué par
rapport à mon dos il ramasse tes papiers
jette à la poubelle c'est un chien écolo
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que les
possibilités existent les adaptations
existe ce n'est pas simple mais c'est
possible
et toute cette aventure elle a été
possible grâce à une immense chaîne de
solidarité qui s'est mise en place dans
toute la france
des inconnus qui nous ont accueillis
partout des partenaires des gens qui
nous ont nourris logés avec les chevaux
le chien des vétérinaires des kinés et
king qui m'ont suivi parce que j'avais
un suivi
dix cas je suis pas parti comme ça et ça
on s'y attendait pas notre action a
touché plus de dix mille personnes
c'est pas tout seul que je suis allé
porter de l'espoir fait tous ensemble
qu'on y est allé je suis parti dans
l'idée de donner puis au final j'ai reçu
tellement plus ça c'était une vraie
surprise même si j'ai encore des
opérations à venir des soins en
permanence et des douleurs incessantes
qui m'en empêche souvent de dormir la
nuit
j'ai décidé de profiter de chaque
seconde
et vous savez quoi je me suis jamais
senti aussi libre que depuis que je suis
handicapé j'ai compris une chose c'est
que les seules vraies limites
ce sont celles que l'on s'impose à soi
même aucune autre aujourd'hui je suis
fier de pouvoir dire que c'est grâce à
mon handicap que j'ai réalisé mon rêve
du tour de france et que je suis en
train d'en écrire le livre c'est grâce à
mon handicap si je suis ici devant vous
c'est grâce à mon handicap j'espère un
jour être paralympiques en équitation et
c'est surtout grâce à mon handicap que
je prends mon pied tous les matins alors
si j'ai pu défier l'impossible pourquoi
pas vous
[Applaudissements]